(bees buzz)
- [Wolfgang] Pollen is the
essence of the flowers.
It's the potential beginning.
It's the male seed for the flowers.
(bees buzz)
Without pollen, there is no plant.
(wind rushes through trees)
I collected the first pollen in 1977.
Since that time,
from early spring until early summer
I was always here
and collected the pollen
just around this small village.
(birds chirp)
(steps crunch softly)
(rustling and soft scraping)
I love this work.
It's something which I
do for hours and hours
and days and days.
It's a very quiet work,
here in this environment
which means a lot to me.
(soft scraping)
Here we have a different jars of pollen.
This is the dandelion pollen,
which I actually collected
this spring, in May.
You see it's not much.
But it took me about three weeks at least.
(soft tapping)
(soft metallic tapping)
Many people always ask me,
"How did you get this idea?"
I think it's not an idea
which you have on an afternoon or so.
I think it's ...
If I look back, it's the ...
intense experience
of studying six years medicine
and seeing the hospitals,
seeing sick people,
experiencing death.
Then, of course, this
has to do all with life,
pollen as the beginning of life,
I think.
I think it was the answer to all
what I had seen before that.
This pollen's just the concentration
of all this 27 years.
The essence of all your experience
is coming into an artwork.
It is as simple as that,
but also as complicated as that.
(traffic rushing, honking)
(soft splashing)
(traffic, honking, and other city noises)
When I work, I want to be totally alone
and I don't want to have
any other influence.
That is the sense that I work in Germany
outside of a small village,
and in India outside of a small village,
totally for myself.
I always found it a luxury
to make my work totally alone,
but to show it in the
biggest cities of the world.
People know me as making
something this year
like the same thing which
I made 30 years ago.
Not many others have
the courage to do that.
For me, that was very important,
but that I would collect the same pollen
this year like 30 years ago.
I find that's a very,
very important statement
in this world, where everything
has to change every second.
(soft tapping)
Art, in the long run,
gives the most to all
the people in the world.
I feel the pollen piece
is much more important than me.
(soft, rhythmic metallic tapping)
In this space here,
I find so incredible that
it's the center of the museum
and it goes through all the floors.
You can see it from the different angles
from the different floors down.
This concept of a center
in such a big building
I find something very beautiful
and very intense and concentrated.
(metallic tapping echoes)
It is very rare that you
can see a pollen piece
from so far above.
And that was always very
beautiful, this distance,
like you are looking down,
not into hell but into heaven.
(rhythmic tapping continues)
It's done.